world of goo schönen guten morgen eine
liebevolle aus berlin und ich sage nicht
einfach nur so guten morgen das ist gar
keine guten morgen sondern wir in
wirklichkeit drei stunden geschlafen und
das ist jetzt gerade wieder halb neun
wir sollten eigentlich jetzt schon mal
zum treffpunkt sein weil wir jetzt ein
video days fahren deswegen jetzt kommen
direkt der bahn durch das aufnehmen
werden
jedenfalls werden wir jetzt vom hotel
abgeholt also schwerlich schillergarten
markt weil der bagger duschen da steht
ja auch noch apple das ist wie lok von
dem zweiten tag in berlin also jetzt am
freitag und expandiert kommt bestimmt
irgendwann bedroht von corpus ich mit
dem was zusammen mit den beiden
geschwindigkeit schon im bett lag davon
haben doch was sie zum respektieren dass
gewinnzahlen und auch schon das ist auf
jeden fall eine entspannte wieder
kameras nie eine 60 das ist auf jeden
fall fahren wir zu dem video des und was
da passiert vielleicht gleich ich weiß
nicht was ich euch folgen gezeigt habe
aber ich kann nicht sagen was ist der
neueste stand der dinge ist wir waren
kurz bei den zuschauern erstmal danke an
alle dass er so korrekt und nicht zu
krass rumgespielt ich habe so eine
flasche willkommen wolf den bionade
davon bekomme ich gleich noch zwei
andere von der zuschauerin danke
andriana an der stelle und jetzt stehen
wir gerade unter anderem die grüße deine
mutter deine katze das ist wundervoll
sorgt dann jedoch andere coole leute die
cola sind als audi habe beispielsweise
apa red
der echte da haben wir noch wissen wir
haben hier felix borja kommen die haben
darf rewe langem einen kanal grantig
wirklich ein bis morgen 30 millionen
abonnenten knacken hier weiß kopien
abonniert mit rio de haben wir auch noch
ihren start noch basti den menschen
gesehen sk haben wir auch schon gesehen
methler quasi
st
so ist es auch jetzt nichts gegen sagen
und diese sei wichtig genau und hier
vorgestellten eingeleitet gesehen hat
sie die ganzen fans in partien auf das
gewohnt sind dass spontan zum 9 10
gefahren weil wir dachten bei dem video
deshalb bei uns zeigen wie das sind sie
aussieht da freund wahrscheinlich gerade
wieder so übergangs sequenzen gesehen
hatten gerade die autogrammstunde halt
abgeschlossen und bei mir was du ich hab
ja gesagt ich möchte keine autogramm
schon machen sondern lieber das ganze
ein bisschen flexibel handhaben und dann
war ich da auch zwei stunden autogramme
geben jeder das bekommen was er wollte
wir sind jetzt gerade irgendwie den
hintereingang geht schon was hier
überall wo ich weiß nicht was in dieser
halle alles mögliche fabriziert wird
aber es sieht auf jeden fall sehr krank
aus jedenfalls sind jetzt auf der
mission das gefühl max albers bändchen
holen müssen das irgendwie immer wieder
verliert dann werde ich euch jetzt
einfach mal noch ein paar andere
youtuber zeigen die heute noch dabei
sind und zwar alle grad noch angekommen
dann hat sich beispielsweise max hatte
ich auch noch gar nicht im blog
ich glaube dass max
ich habe alle leute an welchem wir haben
wir noch so eine sitzecke und hier ist
die ganze stadt zum strähne wer hatte
torwart hat die sache sagen du hast
dieser bereich besser weiß ich jetzt
nicht hier oben umsonst hänge zusammen
linke kennt alleine durch die mythos von
felix rollen oft haben wir von lukas
egger dem ich zu sagen hinter mich nie
gemessen man halte ich eh nicht zu
werden und mir zusammen mit dem jona und
wir werden hier immer ein bisschen
verwundert
sollen himmel da ich die ersten
aufnahmen hier von gestern gewählt noch
von heute morgen da war einfach zu kalt
und bisschen rieseln und alles mögliche
das wetter sich total gebessert wir
hoffen
eine neue wörter hallo wir gehen jetzt
aufgeklärt
übergangslos
danach werden mit dem taxi
wahrscheinlich indisch essen werden
auch wir jetzt diesen ganzen sehr
anstrengender tag wer weniger ausgeben
recht offene youtube
die eröffnung schicken
curry links uns geholt was marty reisen
da kommt so was
wer seine freude das war nicht die
einzige szenige noch aufgenommen hatten
und der google after shop hat
hallo segert im schnitt dass da wohl
irgendwie die speicherkarte folge von
der kamera und ich da keine endlager
machen konnte und dementsprechend die
szenen die ich danach noch aufgenommen
hatte auch nicht vollständig sind es
weil ich gar nicht mehr so viel ich
hoffe dass wir jetzt ist nämlich
aufnehmen wollte das war halt die end
karte deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach
mal es freut mich dass ihr euch das
video bisschen angeschaut habe ich hoffe
euch hatte schnitt gefallen das war
jetzt der richtige video days tag eins
also wirklich der tag wo wir auf dem
video days waren morgen kommt ein video
des tag 2 wo wir dann den zweiten tag
auf dem video days sind und ich hoffe da
schaltet ihr auch wieder ein wenn es
euch gefallen hat schnitt et cetera
aufnahmen alles möglich würde ich mich
über eine wertung freunde findet die
ganzen youtuber die dabei waren und in
der beschreibung verlinkt da findet ihr
auch meine netzwerk mit welcher kamera
ich das alles gewöhnt hat und so weiter
und so fort und dann sehen wir uns
hoffentlich morgen wieder